so as most of you know i uh recently
played international mastery sagar
shah in the i am not a gm speed chess
championship
we had a really fun match i'll leave a
link to full commentary from that match
um then a few days after the match we
hopped on call
to live stream some of our analysis
of our games and in this video i want to
share a clip
of that analysis where we go over some
really cool lines in the ponziani
opening the staffer gambit
and the roy lopez i really think there's
there's a lot to learn
uh in this video and i'll leave
timestamps to
share which opening occurs when so if
you want to hop around
feel free to do so but yeah it's super
cool to have
sagar uh join me on stream and
if you want to watch our full analysis
session i'll leave a link to his
video as well and if you have any
questions or comments
leave them below and i really hope you
enjoy the video
and this one was i think uh
shook me because e45 knight f3 knight c6
bishop
b5 i never which i very rarely play
yeah yes i get like a lot of people uh
maybe some people like request it now
and again it's like one of the most
common openings in chess
uh but i have like all my favorite kind
of pet lines between halloween
gambit and ponziani sometimes danish
gambit that
the spanish gets overlooked i was
actually
studying ponziani and i had like
some some ideas there oh not this sorry
queen f4
and i was planning to play f6 uh and
then bishop b5 and knight g7
yeah we can we can see how my
preparation would have fared i would
have uh
taken on d5 and castle
and i was planning to play e4 oh e4 so
against e4 i would play c4
ah c4 not knight d4 no
c4 is maybe the engine move from well i
remember
oh i i spent a lot of time analyzing
knight d4
and then bishop d7 and i think black is
doing well
here yeah these positions tend to
objectively be a little bit better for
black
but there's some complications like the
the idea with c4 is actually quite cool
is after queen d6 yes to play c5
unleashing the queen so i'm hitting e4
with my queen
of course okay you'll take and then d4
is uh
is a cool move and it just gets really
crazy i don't remember
what happens after this but if i take
here then it's
like bishop i think bishop b3 yeah
rookie one maybe gets some
initiative with open center
c4 queen d6 maybe i shouldn't touch this
pawn right queen d5
but then knight c3 ah knight c3 queen d5
is knight c3
so this is objectively i must take and
then i have to face this
and this would have been quite quite uh
yeah maybe i
should have had my chance to play
ponziani like one game
yeah this would have been nice because i
really spent i thought you will go
knight d4
and then i was prepared but you know the
thing is
like for example this is what adiban
also said to me
that you know it's not only about these
traps like for example the stafford
gambit
sorry knight f6
e5 knight c6 takes
takes uh d3
bishop c5 bishop e oh i was disappointed
you didn't play e4 any game i was ready
to play with stafford
yes but i would have been very happy if
you played the stafford right i mean
i would have been happy too we could
have all been happy
how can uh stafford you know with
someone who's prepared work
so i saw i saw briefly this i guess the
one opening you guys did discuss
on stream was this approach
like in ponziani and i would have been
happy to go into it i would have played
h5 here
yeah and and the thing is h5 um
i mean maybe you would be well prepared
yes
yes c3 so see no one second c3 yes
and this is what i will knight g4 right
yeah uh
d4 queen h4 g3
queen goes back yes f6
and now uh f3 h4 and h oh so if you
prepared beyond this maybe i would have
been in trouble
yeah yeah no i i saw everything like for
example here uh
rook g1 is a move uh so rook g1
is one move but even if you play fg hg
um i think how does this go uh
or maybe you start with through you on
this night are you saying you like you
take the night
and then i saw one video i don't know
who was this there was this player
some strands or something oh jonathan
yeah
he he drew stockfish from uh
from the position after h4 yes
and and this is what ativan showed me
and he said that it's not only about
these traps
like computer will give plus three or
plus four
but the this very deep deep prep like
for example
in that case where he went like gave up
this piece
played bishop p6 i mean it was crazy i
can i can
show the line real quick just uh to have
it on the board
so the line after h4 is rook g1
g1 yeah uh and then
takes takes on g3
and then rook h2 yeah
and then take on c5
bishop e6
uh then queen d4 is this these are all
like stockfish moves from white
basically
and then incredible move and then once
you play those moves the evaluation will
start going down for white
is bishop c4 it's unbelievable like
so so that's the point yeah like it's
not about just preparation
uh i mean you you see it like this is
the same thing which you showed in
ponziani right now
which is like c4 26
c5 takes d4 so you know
more than just the trap you know you
know like how it goes because you have
played it so many times right
so it's not just um the first few moves
you need to know it thoroughly well a
big part also with with
i think jonathan's preparation and i've
been doing this too
is you analyze not just with stock fish
but with leela
and leela will sometimes just disagree
completely with stockfish
and those situations are really
interesting where leela will have a
better sense of like long-term
initiative
and there's situations where stockfish
will say like plus four
but it's actually like close to equal or
just better for
for the other side yeah so so the main
point here is that after bishop c for
having queen f3 uh knight e5
i've uh 95 yeah actually here
uh queen f3 looks right i'm not sure but
uh
queen c4 looks like the most natural
and then okay yeah queen c4 is 95 95
and yeah and the issue becomes there's
these sacrifices on e2 followed by rook
like some rook d8 moves um
[Music]
it's like it's still playable in many of
these lines but
it gets it can get very murky like
rookie 2 queen f3
queen f3 and rook d eight or maybe first
rook d8 i don't know
uh then queen e3 okay
so we wanna and knight d3
i guess this is the level of prep that
uh
you guys have in the staff for
yeah and like it's not the most
practical preparation because not too
many people will go for it but
it can be fun to analyze because there's
so many like beautiful
variations and like one one of the
things with stafford even if
it's objectively bad most players won't
be prepared so deeply and if you're well
prepared you can blitz out the first
15 even 20 moves in some cases
and then just get a huge time advantage
from early on
right um so what's it it's like stafford
is a religion yeah that's what you say
uh yeah that was kind of an offhand joke
but maybe nice there's some element of
truth
to that very cool very cool
okay so uh i went knight c6 and the
the biggest surprise was that you
played this mode d4 which i uh
like i might have prepared at some point
but i didn't have
like before the game uh gotcha yeah
i've i've played this in classical
tournament
chess which maybe you didn't check maybe
only i
checked a bit of classical but not this
deep like i was just seeing what your
style
and then you for the opening i i based
it on
uh your online games gotcha
yeah it would have been impressive if
you found my games from this line
um but okay bishop g4 is well known to
be
like kind of equalizing after the game i
realized that you should take
take knight day five bishops so
it was funny uh i i have a small story
to share
from exactly this line so
right after our match um i decided to
live stream
title tuesday on chess.com
um because i couldn't get like enough
chess
and then in one of the games in title
tuesday i went into this variation
and i played through all of my
preparation it was i think 17 moves deep
and my opponent walks straight into like
a nice trap
let's mix let's play e4
i play the spanish against sagar maybe
i'll repeat the spanish
i usually um like on stream i i play
ponziani but
i prepared this like this tricky spanish
sign
okay so black might go for a marshall if
i play c3 so i'll play d4 here
it's a tricky line and now c3
so i had the same positioning in sagar
and he thought for maybe 30 seconds and
played this move
uh yeah this is still prep knight d2 is
a bit offbeat
because i i willingly give black the
bishop pair
but the point is after c5 main move
i'll play h3g4
and there's a cool idea after bishop h5
g4
i looked at this right before the match
and knight h4
and black can't take the pawn even
though it looks undefended
it takes here i take here remove the
guard and that's a blunder because g5
and i went to peace
so that was nice 17 moves of opening
preparation
ending with g5
it's nice to like be prepared so deeply
um and it emerges from uh
what you just showed c takes d4 c takes
d4
it was nice because the whole game i
just didn't really have to think at
least the first uh
opening moves so in this position um not
bishop c2 but
knight b d2 uh-huh
allowing knight takes b3 yeah so black
gets the bishop here a b3
c5 and then the idea here is to play h3
okay bishop h5 okay
bishop g6 now very uh very nice move
and i found this at some point a few
years ago with the engine
is knight h4
um and my opponent in title tuesday
walked right into this
very quickly took on e4 with the bishop
the e4 pawn can't be taken here
um yeah i would uh guess i would also do
it because 94 94 h4 is also hanging
i mean so just a free pawn wait to move
find the simple tactic to win a piece
okay
simple tactic
so it's white to move here and
oh oh this is very cool
this is very cool actually somehow it's
not easy to spot it instantly right
because it's not a common one
yeah it's a slightly unusual pattern
your knights on h4 but it just it's
it is like a basic removal of the guard
you want to win the bishop
and you want to remove the knight from
f6
so g5 yeah
i'm currently living in st louis okay
but
i grew up uh in the chicago suburbs
so nice not too far away
great okay so uh
g5 is the winning move ah very cool so
here
so here black has to do something you
could take on d4 or you can play rook e8
but then like white's going to follow
through with knight f5 very soon
um it's a playable position
nice that's some king side play have
them this is this is the
typical eric yeah like everyone tells
you in the opening don't give up this
bishop
you say you're lying right lupus bishop
but he's like okay
i don't mind i there's some like deeper
yeah
a lot of it can be based on like unusual
moves
i'll just try and make work with the
engine
is this something from before you used
to do or it's just specific to streaming
this
trying to find unusual and some nice
traps and stuff like that
uh this i i enjoy well before streaming
um i mean i grew up using
chess bass and when i would play in
tournaments when i know my opponent
ahead of time
and can then look up their games then
i'll
try and find their games in jazz base
and use the engine use databases to come
up with with new things
um right so yeah i've been using chat
space since i was probably like nine
years old
nice so cool uh and so
i tried to follow up the normal way
which is not the
the best way to play you create
the thing is i didn't know what to do
against rookie it was like out of my
preparation
so yeah yeah i knew that like i knew
that uh
this is a bad move when you started
thinking uh
over here so i mean not bad but it might
not be the main line
uh yeah which like sometimes you want to
actually go for like play a move that's
out of my book and then you guys are
hoping
i'm just hoping that there's no bishop
f7 here
yeah i wanted to make bishop f7 queen b3
but there's always d5 yeah d5
and i don't think it quite works for
white
yeah so knight d2
bishop f8 h3 and here i
i just played d5 because generally if
you get d5 in such structures it's it's
a good idea
but you played very well like g4
excellent move
i was thinking should i take but i
didn't i didn't find anything here
after edie and somehow bishop e4 may
come next right
there's enough defenders on the king
side
yeah and so i i took here
takes takes and this is where uh e5
i thought that black should be fine
uh but i found this later and this is
very cool that after 94
d4 oh this position i i missed an
opportunity i checked this game too
yes it's a it's a very nice one i
thought black should be fine
because of two reasons one is that you
have slight weaknesses here my queen is
coming to h4
but this is a very nice move here for
white
right and i i don't know if i even
consider this move think i was just
focused on
[Music]
a single idea and didn't even like
consider my other options
but it's a type of move like once you
once you see as an option
it makes a ton of sense of like why it
can be so good
yeah yeah
i i think here guys if you can find the
move this is very nice
in fact eric i i think that i would have
gone for this
like every time and but now that i see
this white
move i realize that my strategy may be
wrong you know like
to go for this position
sure and i don't know if there is a
better improvement after rookie 8 but
um yeah maybe you would go for like the
knight a5 line
yes i will go for 95 next time 80 40 64.
so i'm not seeing anyone in my chat
finding the move a lot of people
actually i think suggesting the move
that i
that you play yes yeah this is not an
easy move
and it's yeah it's like one of these
positional exercises
so it's not tactics like some people i
see
wanting to take on e4 but it's way more
just about getting the optimal
piece placement targeting some weakness
so in the game eric played f4 and after
ef3
bishop g6 hg6 and queen f3 i think black
is doing fine
i mean because one bishop is exchanged
but
the real cool move is bishop f4
and the idea is that if queen h4
you can go king g2 and then bishop g3
kick the queen out
at the same time this is a weakness now
and also
queen d5 can always be met with bishop
b3
pushing the pawn to d5 and white has a
very strong position
yeah and for some reason i don't think i
was fully aware that i have this bishop
b3 resource
against queen d5 and not only that but
like after bishop b3
i can potentially get my pawn to d5 yes
with
like both your bishops supporting the
pawns it's
and the pawns just control so much space
the queen can come to d4
my rook comes to c1 as just a dream
position and black is so passive
correct very nice so this
uh would have been very good but after
f4 i think
this game it was one of the rare ones
which reached a logical conclusion it
was our only draw of the match actually
really i think so oh
because we we ended at each having like
0.5
right right right yeah yeah only draw
and i i think
uh this was an equal position and it
ended in a draw so
so good uh it was a good game i would
say
uh eric had some chances but
in the end it was drawn